to search pubmed for works by a
specific author i entered the author's last name and
initials in the search box
use no punctuation
let's search for articles by fiona
melanie wood burn specialist
and inventor of skin spray
we have entered wood fm in the search box
search
click on search
pop med locates articles by authors
with the last name and initials that were
used in the search
if there are several authors with the same
last name and initials search for an article
that you know is from the author of your interest
I am looking for articles from a  the lei
baker who researches pancreatic cancer
the author we are looking for has
contributed to the article modeling
pancreas and cancer uicc organs
click on this article
on the article abstract screen
click on the author's name
when clicking on the name  from an author
in pubmed runs an
author algorithm calculated using
names of institutions and terms with authors  by
reference this algorithm finds other
articles that are likely to be by the
same author and moves them to the
top of the search results
another way to search for articles by an
author is by using an advanced search
in the search builder section
select author
enter multiple characters from the
author's last name then select author's name
from the autocomplete menu enter
barijhoff di
and select rod dj
some pop med records but not
all contain the full author's name
for the most
complete results use only the author's last name and
initials
do  click on and
then click on search
to find all works in pubmed
by this author